tell me I won't yeah basically fifteen
[Music]
there's a foster couple outside mr.
Batson I can take care of myself give
these people a chance cuz that's what
they're giving you
Billy is a foster kid he's been in and
out of foster homes this is Billy Batson
he's a really good kid who wants the
best who sticks up for the other kid hey
man sorry about that hand because he was
pure of heart baby backs these
transports of this wizard I choose you
as champion whoo and douse him with his
power of Shazam Shazam he has this power
of just saying one word and turning into
a superhero his friend Freddy you're the
only person I know that knows anything
about this Cape Crusader stuff what are
your superpowers I don't even know how
to pee in this everybody is Charlie we
got a whole bunch of new trailers this
morning we'll start with Shazam footage
we got a look at the Shazam family a
whole bunch of new locations and a
couple of their really big bites I think
we also got a look at the secret
location of the rock of eternity to so
we'll break it down there's a new round
of the IMAX ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a Sam comment on the video so if
you couldn't tell from all the snow this
is set during the holiday period at the
end of the year that's why there's so
many Christmas themes at that big
carnival set where one of their big
final battles takes place when you see
them blow up this ferris wheel the
director clarified that they did that in
real life that's a practical effect that
they just enhanced with a little bit of
CG and post-production and you actually
noticed here too the carnival people
have been asking about tony the tiger
they have all these tony the tiger
plushies behind them here and the
director did say that they were
including lots of toy Easter eggs for
Superman Batman the Justice League
Wonder Woman pretty much all those
characters the flash cyborg but there's
a joke in the movie with a toy store
that we haven't seen yet where they go
and there's all these unlicensed toys
that don't look like the actual Justice
League heroes they're not made to look
like Henry Cavill and Ben Affleck's
Batman so there's a joke about that in
the film it might have something to do
with this Christmas themed carnival here
with all the ripoff prizes that you
would find at a carnival
this like here give us $10 worth of
tickets and we'll give you this plushy
toy that's worth $1 you see him flying
through downtown then he's landing
somewhere outside the city it's kind of
dark in this frame so it's hard to tell
but it's not the same location where he
pounds his fist on the pavement that's
actually right after he gets his powers
for the first time and he doesn't
realize his own strength like he starts
out 15 year-old Billy Batson then boom
all of a sudden he's crushing pavement
because he's so strong this is another
shot during one of those big final
battles of the carnival he's sitting in
this giant crater here so they've
already been fighting for a little while
when he's standing here they released a
couple high-res images this is a much
better look at what this scene is
there's a scene of him racing away from
Freddy Freeman on the playground this is
either when they're testing his powers
or when he's just rushing into battle
trying to help someone but notice the
way they visualize his SuperSpeed and
how different it looks from the flash
and the way he runs super fast when he's
using his Speed Force abilities so this
is just to distinguish his speed from
the Flash's speed Billy Batson powers
are magical so obviously it's very
different source of speed than the Speed
Force itself the flash is still supposed
to be as the name implies the fastest
man alive
so Billy Batson is still super fast
almost as fast as Superman but not quite
as fast as the flash
the thing about Billy Batson speed
versus Superman speed is that he doesn't
just additionally get more power as he
stands under Earth's Yellow Sun so the
more energy Superman absorbs the faster
- the more powerful he gets but when
Billy Batson gets all the powers of
Shazam here at the rock of eternity like
right from the beginning he gets a
hundred percent of all those powers it's
the wisdom of Solomon the strength of
Hercules the stamina of Atlas the power
of Zeus the courage of Achilles in the
speed of mercury so his power level is
just relative to how well he learns to
use his abilities but he's already at a
hundred percent
that's why later in the comic book story
he winds up sharing the power with the
rest of the Shazam family because it's
way more than he can use at any one time
and he could only use one power per time
so like he has to say wisdom of Solomon
and that'll make him really smart until
he calls out a different power so
strength of Hercules it'll make him
really strong so it goes way deeper than
that but that's just how they explain he
can't use every single ability all at
the same time which is why he's a little
bit weaker against people like Superman
unless he's using the power of Zeus for
a special magical lightning bolts
maybe someday when they cross over in a
Justice League movie who knows you know
five six years down the road we'll see a
version of that just to show you how
Suzanne can be cool against some of
these other characters this is actually
a really cool shot here this is magical
portal opening between these two
buildings I don't know if this is a
Philadelphia landmark but I think that
this is the secret location of the rock
of eternity in the comics it's located
at a special magical Nexus it's just
hidden from view from plain sight so I'm
guessing the reason why it seems like
its unveiling itself is because maybe
this is when dr. sivana tries to release
the seven deadly sins is implied that
that's kind of where the movie is headed
because they sort of tease them in this
shot here where a young version of dr.
sivana noticed the clothes that he's
wearing said many many years ago when
the wizard was trying to name him as his
successor obviously things went down the
crapper I think they talked a little bit
about it before the movie came out the
director said that dr. sivana had a
really terrible relationship with his
family and if you remember all the
family shots that they have in the
previous trailers they try to show you
how Billy doesn't feel like he has a
family he doesn't trust anyone so it's
sort of like the darker version of what
Billy could become if he doesn't
completely embrace this family and if
you've ever read any of the comics
obviously you kind of know where they're
headed with that direction but I talked
about in a couple of the trailer videos
dr. sivana is getting a lot of the
themes of black Adams story not the
literal story it's up like he's not five
thousand years old or anything like that
but he's another candidate that comes
from a broken family and things are
really terrible they're just making it
dr. sivana in this movie because they
don't want to do Black Adam yet in dr.
sivana is more contemporary even though
he's very very old during the course of
events in this movie like he's actually
aged up to his real age so like in the
comics Billy Batson is always a little
kid that looks like he's an adult when
he has his powers but obviously in the
future he'll just age like a normal
human so that eventually he'll look like
Zachary Levi even when he's not using
his powers we haven't seen any actual
footage of the seven deadly sins
themselves outside of them just being
trapped in their little avatars here
these little statues so we've seen some
toys of them I don't know what they're
gonna look like in the actual finished
movie but I wouldn't be surprised if
they kept that out of all the trailers
you don't necessarily need to include
that because they're sort of a red
herring it's sort of like a MacGuffin
like these are the things that are so
dangerous the seven deadly enemies of
man that you need to keep trapped here
that actually is the
only reason why the wizard is passing
his power along because Billy or his
successor whoever that winds up being is
meant to protect man from the seven
deadly enemies of man that's why they're
called that and that's why dr. sivana
turns on them and tries to release them
during the comics there's a scene of dr.
sivana coming after the whole Shazam
family in their foster home here you can
see freddy freeman Mary Marvel Darla
Eugene and Pedro on the couch behind
them this might be towards the middle of
the film because it seems like he's only
just now telling dr. sivana how old he
really is but he's at his house so
either he follows him there or he learns
his true ability but because dr. sivana
has a lot of the same abilities as
Shazam black atom style he has the
wisdom of Solomon he's probably just
able to discern who Billy is based on
where he goes this is the same shot that
we've been seeing from the carnival and
all those big final battles it may not
be the final battle but it's probably
one of the last big battles just because
it seems like they're hyping this up so
much there's a new funny scene of Billy
and Freddy Freeman
trying to sneak out of the house getting
caught by Darla can she keep a secret no
definitely not she could totally not
keep a secret it seems like the clear
set up here is that Darla is gonna run
and tell the rest of the Shazam family
and maybe they try to go out and help
Billy
so this could be happening later in the
film or maybe it's when they just go out
to test their powers but eventually they
all do learn that Billy is this Shazam
person and the giant body this is him in
public after he's been busking either
he's just taking off to go somewhere
else or it's during that first encounter
with dr. sivana oh you're like a bad guy
right where he just totally figures it
out in dr. sivana just gets super pissed
off and starts pounding him in the
middle of the air there's a new shot of
him saving Mary Marvel from the snow
plow this is probably earlier in the
film before she knows that it's Billy
because it seems like the joke hears it
is a bit of a twist on a Superman Lois
Lane saved like oh thank you my hero how
wonderful who are you wonderful stranger
with all these superpowers but secretly
it's her foster brother Billy hopefully
they don't ship the two of them or
anything like that they're not actually
related but they are foster brother and
sister and this isn't Game of Thrones
but this is the same shot of him running
off the building activating his powers
probably towards the end of the film
after he's more confident with his
abilities because he would break every
bone in his body if he hit the ground
there's another shot of the funny
convenience store saved when he learns
that he's bulletproof then you have the
featurette of Zachary
Levi and the director and the actors
talking about the characters the thing
that I love about this the way the
Zachary Levi talks about it is that he's
a kid that is genuinely excited to have
powers he doesn't treat them like a
burden and he's excited to be a
superhero like he is ready to go he's
not jaded it's not like he's been doing
this for 40 years like ah this is
wearing me down another person to save
it I can't believe that this is such a
burden my abilities they're so terrible
I wish that it didn't have them nothing
is worse than a superhero who has
amazing powers and wishes that they
didn't have those powers but just
because there's so much Shazam family in
all the more recent trailers that are
dropping I think that this is clearly
building towards a comic book
Shazam storyline because it's based on
the Jeff Johnson's new 52 story and at
the end of that story he grants all the
other members of the Shazam family part
of his power as you would assume the way
they use it for visual purposes just to
make it pop a little bit more on-screen
when they're all fighting together is
that they're all using a different
abilities so that at any given time
every single power of Shazam is being
used as opposed to someone like Black
Adam or dr. sivana in the Shazam movie
who can only use one power at a time
I've already talked a little bit about
how I feel like they'll include a lot of
Easter eggs and the post-credits scenes
for Black Adam there's been talk of a
Superman post-credit scene without
actually using Henry Cavill like they
don't show his face so he's a little off
screen but Superman is involved in the
film because they're such a big part of
this world that they live in there's
such superhero fanboys of course do you
want to include Justice League stuff but
post all your theories in the comments
below and we'll happen is is they just
dropped a brand new detective Pikachu
trailer with Ryan Reynolds so I'll do an
Easter Egg video for that that should be
up in the next couple of hours while you
wait for everything click here to my
flash season 5 god speed teaser that's
right Godspeed coming to the TV show and
click here for my brand-new Game of
Thrones season 8 trailer video thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]